by the way and see love and we talked
about in the beginning that scene you
get to see see develop but there's this
scene that's great where I couldn't
believe I didn't remember but I watched
it but you with Pacino you're beating
the [ __ ] out of each other yeah and you
get on him yeah from behind yeah yeah I
know that you came up with this cuz it
wasn't written oh I'm gonna rape him
like he he I'm gonna you think that he
take his clothes off you think he reigns
Oh raping and kill him because you think
someone he raped someone you loved yeah
and you are now on top of him when I see
this you're not Bobby see your club but
you're beating the ship [ __ ] and he's
got him he's beating the [ __ ] up and
then he acts just like he's grinding him
at the end I was like [ __ ] that was your
choice wasn't it director didn't say
Rucker can you act like you're [ __ ]
now yo though well the Lions give you
your hints your lies the line do you
remember the line the line was what did
you do show me what you did do is show
me how you did it you know
and as I'm ripping his clothes off and
I'm about to I'm about to rape this guy
and then kill him boys brains out right
and so in the meantime he grabs the the
little rope locks you in the head
rubbing it clocks me in the head and
then the fights on right a dumbbell or
something yeah it was a trophy it was a
shooting or a trophy and he hits me in
the head and I go back and then we
worked out with the stunt guys and with
him we we both did a lot of our own
style long did that take the choreograph
that see him and how long did it take to
shoot it took about a day a full day it
was out great to work with yeah I
thought he was great to work it well he
we understood each other really crystal
clear after the first take how so well
first take he tried choking me up really
like really and then what'd you do
well I did what I was supposed to do in
the scene we should spin around and to
launch my 210 pound frame with him on my
back into the wall and you did it of
course a little harder a little extra
huh I did it his way he was supposed to
do it did you hurt him I think we were
both hurting at that point and did he
say hey sorry about that
no he looked up to me after he after he
fell from my back
and his arms left my neck he looked up
at me he said am i [ __ ] you know you
don't see the choking too hard am i he
said it he said to her am I too hard and
I go did I too hard and he goes that was
it that was it we understood each other
crystal but you weren't gonna stop that
scene you're like Al Pacino's choked I
mean I'm not gonna stop no no no joke me
no if I stopped I would have been I
would have been taken out he would have
put me to sleep it's the most intense
scene it sounds like a light-hearted
romp oh my god I totally would've been
put to sleep I was going out I was
seeing nothing but black black black
black black